aujourd'hui c'est le solstice d'été le
jour le plus long de l'année dans
l'hémisphère nord
ici à quelques kilomètres de paris le
soleil aura donc briller aujourd'hui
pendant un peu plus de 16 heures avant
de se coucher
alors que dans six mois au moment du
solstice d'hiver la durée du jour ne
cédera pas 8h15
bochum alors pourquoi cette durée varie
t elle autant c'est parce qu'au fil des
mois la terre ne présentent pas le même
visage au soleil vous savez elle tourne
autour de lui une révolution en un peu
plus de 365 jours mais ce n'est pas tout
mais la terre tourne aussi sur elle-même
comme une toupie fait un tour complet en
24 heures mais autour d'un axe qui est
incliné par rapport au plan de
l'écliptique servir le plan dans lequel
la terre se déplace autour du soleil
cette inclinaison d'un peu plus de 23
degrés par rapport à la verticale et
déterminer s'ils axe de rotation de la
terre était perpendiculaire au plan de
l'écliptique comme ici la durée du jour
et de la nuit serait parfaitement eyal
où que ce soit sur terre 365 jours sur
autrement dit quelle que soit la
position de la terre par rapport au
soleil
mais ce n'est pas le cas
à cause de cette inclinaison durant le
voyage de la terre autour du soleil
les pôles sont plus ou moins orienté
vers le soleil l'éclairage des
hémisphères varie donc d'une saison à
l'autre quand la terre se trouve dans
cette position l'hémisphère nord et
moins éclairés que l'hémisphère sud
les jours sont plus courts au nord qu'au
sud
c'est l'hiver sous nos latitudes six
mois plus tard celle inverse
l'hémisphère nord et plus éclairés que
l'hémisphère sud
en 2020 le 20 juin étant le jour où
l'unc de rotation point que plus vers le
soleil c'est donc jour le plus long
très concrètement ce jour là chaque
point de l'hémisphère nord reste plus
longtemps dans la lumière que les autres
jours et c'est ainsi que les fleurs de
mon jardin peuvent profiter ce jour là
de plus de 16 heures de lumière et les
abeilles aussi qui visuellement ce jour
là le soleil monte très haut dans le
ciel un peu plus de 60 degrés par
rapport à l'horizon à l'endroit où je me
trouve alors au solstice d'hiver
il reste en dessous de 18 degrés alors
ces derniers jours la marche pour
atteindre le point culminant a été tout
petit et ce sera exactement la même
chose dans les jours qui viennent quand
ils vont commencer à diminuer les
paliers seront minuscule
vue du plancher des vaches on a
l'impression pendant cette période que
le soleil ne bouge enfin que son point
culminant reste à la même hauteur et
c'est d'ailleurs le sens du mot solstice
sol pour soleil et ce dix du latin star
et qui signifie être immobile il ya
quand même quelque chose d'étrange
avez vous gardé des agendas des années
précédentes l'année dernière le solstice
a eu lieu le 21 juin et non le vin année
prochaine il aura de nouveau lieu le 21
en 2022
rebelote en fait il faut attendre 2024
pour que le solstice se produise à
nouveau le vagin alors pourquoi ce
décalage
je les dis un peu plus tôt la terre
tourne autour du soleil en un peu plus
de 365 jours 365 jours 5 heures 48
minutes et 45 secondes l'année civile et
donc un peu plus court que l'année trop
peu pour rattraper ce retard
les maîtres du temps rajoute donc
régulièrement une journée supplémentaire
au calendrier civil une tous les quatre
ans ce sont les fameuses années
bissextiles
ces années là comme en 2020 le solstice
a lieu le 20 juin
seulement ce rattrapage n'est pas tout à
fait suffisant car la trajectoire de la
terre autour du soleil n'est pas
toujours exactement la même
sans compter que l'inclinaison de l'axé
de rotation varie légèrement
du coup le solstice d'été peut aussi
avoir lieu le 22 juin
comme ce fut le cas en 1975 et comme ce
sera le cas en 2002 sans trois c'est
loin et plus rare encore le 19 prochaine
édition 2488
2488 est ce que cette capsule existera
encore
du coup j'ai une bouffée de chaleur
pas vous enfin ça c'est normal car le
solstice marque aussi le début de l'été
la saison la plus chaude dans les
régions tempérées et contrairement à une
idée reçue ce n'est pas parce que la
terre est plus proche du soleil durant
son trajet elle dessine une ellipse et
c'est même le moment où elle en est le
plus éloigné
en fait s'il fait plus chaud c'est
encore une fois à cause de l'inclinaison
de l'axé de rotation à cause de cette
inclinaison l'hiver l'europe de l'ouest
se trouve à cette hauteur elle était
elle se trouve ici plus bas la quantité
de lumière qui chauffe une zone allant
de l'ecosse à l'espagne en hiver ne
chauffent plus que la france en été
l'été le roman est donc meilleur voilà
pourquoi il fait plus chaud je pourrais
bien quelque chose moi pas ça c'est une
autre histoire
à la semaine prochaine et d'ici là
profitez bien les chaque point de
l'hémisphère nord reste plus longtemps
dans la lumière de leurs cette année le
solstice d'été
au moment du solstice d'hiver au moment
du saulcy
[Musique]